No.
What are they paying for?
You're paying for that fun that's associated with the anticipation of the reward
and the brain.
You know,
your,
your emotional brain isn't that great at calculating mathematically
probabilities.
And so it sort of says some chance you have some chance of winning $50 million.
Well,
it might be one in 380 million,
but your,
you know,
your anticipation system isn't a mathematical system.
It just says,
well,
you have some chance that's a lot more than none.
Well,
in some ways it's infinitely more than none because at zero you have no chance.
And you know,
with one tech you have some chance.
So that gets the old excitement going.